c'est vrai que ça ça a été précieux la
récolte même s'ils font en exclusivité
je vous le dis tout de suite alors on a
pu voir donc dans l'émission jolie raul
donc l'éleveur donc qu'ils connaissaient
déjà
laetitia ayez le plein de tweets en fait
raul et iselle sont déjà ensemble mais
ont voulu se faire payer un petit voyage
à paris à façon de se faire la bise et
se regarder ça se voit qu'il se
connaître je comprends pas l'intérêt de
nous montrer raul et sa meuf vu que tout
est déjà fait c'est déjà les héros de
challenge le candidat d'expliquer donc à
la production qu'il avait déjà rencontré
quelqu'un avant le début de l'amour est
dans le pré et étant donné qu'il avait
un contrat il a décidé de continuer
l'aventuré et de jouer à fond
l'ouverture des courriers alors est-ce
que ça alors vous avez des infos là
dessus et qu'elles ont compté va les
régler
alors raul a en fait il a rencontré
cette jeune femme dans une foire
agricole quelques jours avant le début
du programme
ah ouais et il ya eu un truc qui s'est
passé un truc rien n'avait été consommés
mais santé qu'on fait passer quelque
chose et donc la jeune femme elle s'est
dit qu'est ce que je vais faire avec son
accord je vais envoyer une lettre à la
production pour faire comme une
candidate langue d'arrêt maladie c'est
évidemment sélectionnés et lui a dit à
la production moi je n'ouvre qu'une
seule lettre la sienne et je ne veux
jouer aucun autre c'est une manipulation
même si c'est vrai ça normal boban vous
dites confiantes et moi j'ai dit que non
oui on en veux mais tu es où il a dit
tout de suite aujourd'hui moi je suis un
téléspectateur meurtrier blessés c'était
mon émission préférée mais aussi on nous
mentaient c'est une magouille mais non
il se relève
attendez c'est pas fini et la réponse de
6,6 aussi peut-être sur vincent qui va
me laisser pascal avant les autos matrix
qui avait été visité par isabelle avant
ça fait trois visites
alors c'est vrai c'est une émission de
télé attendez attendez vincent alors
maintenant je suis un autodidacte a
avoué avoir déjà rencontré xiu plaît
bien pensants qui a déjà avoué avoir
rencontré déjà sa prétendante avant le
speed dating regarder ça aussi c'est ce
que vous dites c'est maintenant le speed
dating
c'est pas la première fois que je vois
une fois parce qu'elle a trouvé mon
numéro de téléphone et ça a pris
bon moi il est mis deux mois pour que ce
week-end et il était déjà plus avec
c'était le monde d'accord et la
promession savais que je l'avais vu à 20
puis quand on a fait les films dating
non moi j'ai bien été clair avec la
production j moi je n'ai vite et appuie
dating et à un nombre de faire toutes
les choses il faudrait comme puisse être
honnête par rapport à l'émission et il
dire les choses mais alors laetitia
justement a réagi de l'amour est dans le
pré puisqu'elle a mis un tweet et là ça
m'a pas ça va pas aller dans le sens
d'isabelle je vous le dis ils disent à
la mode il y avait déjà eu un baiser
avec raul avant le speed dating il
s'était déjà pc bien sûr elle a dit ça
c'est les loisirs
donc voilà ben helli mais ouais alors l
ipad il avait dit qu'il ya un petit truc
mais c'était déjà pécho donc vous dites
non donc m6 est clean là dessus je
rappelle tout peut-être dans groupe rtl
atteint a été racheté par un héros
pertes et je suis l'émission depuis 12
ans à vous et merci marché qu'on compte
les bouses absolument pas choqué et tout
le monde est clair dans cette affaire
n'ont absolument pas empêché ce que
après la diffusion des portraits en
janvier par la presse locale par les
réseaux sociaux pas mal tout le monde
maintenant essayent de contourner la
production est de contacter pour
aller très vite et je trouve qu'il n'ya
pas manipulation des masses non isabelle
défend très mal n c'est ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que oui même si c'est un
programme qui promet c'est pareil maman
cabinet cges que géré par la ce et que
évidemment que sur ce coup là c'est pas
clean et sur ce coup là m6 n'a pas été
clean en revanche il faut pas se servir
du une seule fois sur des miniers des
mines et à celle du laurent juste pour
animer comme tu le dis en année 3 fois
aura toujours des gens malhonnêtes mais
vrai faux brave passeur de ce cas là
mais oui sur ce cas là effectivement il
ya rien à dire qu'il a été mitigée il ya
certes un énorme carton et son premier
de la soirée
moi c'est mon émission les bains dans
l'émission les valeurs sélectionnées
ils ont tout organisé autour de ce mec
si après la chope henin quinze jours
avant bah voilà ouais bah le fait
d'ajouter dans le frimas temps du doute
est dans le fruit
heureusement qu'il est dans les
histoires et qu'on fait les villes sont
comme ça il faut que les vaches et les
candidats tu prends ou paie un ministre
à qui sont passés par la réponse dames 6
les cherry en régie s'il vous plaît
aussi à lui faire porter aux îles exacte
et la production jusqu'à vent pourrait
demander de censurer et de supprimer du
montage ce couple parce que cette
nombreux étaient les spectateurs
toujours des bana les journalistes
servirait c'est un des rédacteurs en
chef de deux étages
excusez moi travailler un petit peu et
d'être objectif
[Applaudissements]
j'ai appelé j'ai appelé la production et
nous ont indiqué que pour eux il n'y
avait pas de problème c'est pas grave si
le couple se voir en dehors des caméras
parce qu'il voulait surtout les devoirs
l'afld laetitia comment elle allait se
comporter dans le monde agricole tout ça
et c'est juste une honte parce que les
téléspectateurs ce qui va le voir c'est
l'amour c'est l'amour naître et là il ya
plus d'un mois étant donné qu'ils voient
en dehors des caméras donc ça n'a plus
aucun intérêt
il ya eu il ya une pole alors on va voir
ce que disent les téléspectateurs juste
christine est pas ce qu'est une autre
polémique où on voit revenir là dessus
sur une déclaration car inouïe dans les
conventions
oui le sol est passé sur arte mais dans
les conventions qui lient le sait ça
enchaîne oui la chaîne se doit
oui obligatoirement l'honnêteté de
l'information d'accord voilà donc tout
ça pour dire que à partir du moment où
la production m6 et donc qui vit à lui
arnaquer bruel à dire au téléphone
alors est ce qu'ils vont bien c'est
comme ça dans tous les cas six de nos
étoiles partout mais vous rigolez le roi
de la magouille
le casting une production in chaîne
quand il faut une émission de télévision
ils veulent un bon casting m'a
évidemment dans tous les cas parfois il
ya des cas on sait très bien que où le
secret n'est pas le secret ou que je
suis venu et qu'on eksi n'est pas son
iphone dans les exemples parce que dans
son procès bis et vanessa un leur secret
c'était donc pas de secret story s'est
restauré bon je décrypte à emilie et
vanessa lorsque c'était je suis avec ma
maison mon pire ennemi
les deux se connaissaient très bien il
n'était pas du tout et demi huawei est
arrivé avec ses comme agathe et kenny
mois exactement enquêtes du sénat n'a
rentré que secret je suis aimé deux ex
johnex je suis jamais allé de son but
[Rires]
je sais que les dosettes deux ex est
entièrement mon grand père n'est pas
vrai c'est totalement faux donc ça veut
dire quoi
donc tu plais forte les packs tout est
ce que vous êtes vraiment marier ce que
je dis ce que je veux dire c'est parfois
il ya des choses qui sont vraies mais
parfois on fait un choix de producteurs
la chaîne est parfaitement au courant et
ont fait un choix pour signaler le savez
déjà passé lancé annoncé mais lui c'est
une fessée ça vous est une horreur ou
non mais mais le truc c'est qu'en fait
ce qui est amusant et ce qui est un peu
perverse et que les candidats jouent le
jeu eux mêmes du mensonge qui sont ils
le jouent en complicité avec la
production énergivores
alors vous souvenez vous voulez savoir
si on arrache des marchés dans le 4e
match à roger de fermeture est pas moi
je suis sûr qu'elle va tuer alors il y
aura ou lutter a voulu faire comprendre
à sa prétendante justement quelle est la
seule à être venu au speed dating et ça
voilà c'était un peu chelou pour les
téléspectateurs
j'aime le théâtre
e
il ya peu il n'y a pas eu d'autres jette
s'ils la valident
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas de speed dating et
bekoto duty la seule il ya deux ans à la
religion qui soit solide
et j'ai envie que ce tapis
[Rires]
[Musique]
maria se sentir un peu mes nerfs sur
cette affaire parce que je suis sûr que
tu fais l'amour est dans le pré qui
n'ont même pas mais tu tombes dans je
suis une grande fan de télé réalité des
missions de touche assuré que j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec avec ça en fait le
problème je pense que c'est à certaines
règles à respecter dans ce genre
d'émission et que dans celle ci et plein
d'autres mais là on parle de celle ci je
pense que celle du hasard doit être
respectée tu vois ça apprendra enfin
d'un point de vue je pense d'eux tu vois
deux présentateurs et non c'est pas mal
restons donc tu sais comment ça marche
comment le trouvez les téléspectateurs
et les spectateurs d'accord c'est vrai
que sur twitter les gens sont plus
énervés mais bon ils sont assez honnête
je vous dis dans l'amour est dans le pré
il ya eu deux trois trucs comme ça
qu'ils ont un peu dérapé mais je trouve
qu'ils sont assez honnête